I think you've made something like
is this do I have this number right 30
million dollars through like
only fans and like your other kind of
platforms where people subscribe to you
yeah that's just on L.A fans though but
yes just on only fans what is the do you
have like a total number that's even
more impressive oh God I haven't really
looked in a while but maybe like 40
million or something something like that
[Music]
all right what's up we just had
um Kate also known as amaranth on the
podcast she is I think the number one
Creator on only fans she has made over
30 million dollars on only fans into
like two years so it's kind of insane
what she's done building up a following
and then turning that into like I don't
know she's probably one of the top
earners on social media period and most
people don't know about her or ever
heard of her so I thought that was
pretty pretty cool uh Sam what'd you
think did any of the stats that she said
surprise you or shock you well I had
heard the money part out like before
this which is why I was like interested
in she reached out to us to be like hey
can I come on the Pod and uh and so you
know I was down for it for that but
that's the most shocking number uh the
other part that was shocking was just
that she was pretty nonchalant about it
I was pretty surprised at how
sophisticated her Empire is you know she
talks about how she's now offering the
serve she basically built this media
Empire and now she's offering it as an
agency to other women and she kind of
dismissed it as like yeah just this
small thing and I have a feeling it's
significantly bigger than she kind of
like the energy that she was giving out
and I find that to be incredibly
fascinating yeah I think she's kind of a
killer in terms of like how she's like
how she's done it right how she built
her brand I mean she's basically like
okay Kim Kardashian built like a mega
brand kind of doing this stuff and like
you know has turned it into a TV show
and all kinds of other things but like
in the social media World she's kind of
like on that level right she's like
pretty A-list in the world of social
media in terms of how many social media
people can pull in tens of millions of
dollars a year the very very few with
like a five-person staff with like yeah
with like you know a small team behind
him and not even in a category where
you're getting like you know mainstream
brand deals from like whoever you know
like Coca-Cola or whatever yeah it was
it was really fascinating so hope you
guys enjoy it
hi Caitlin I was downloading Zoom then I
realized it wasn't Zoom so whoops
anyways I'm here hello welcome welcome
to the show
um you are one of the most interesting
potential guests that I've wanted on the
show we've had
people who made money in different ways
we've had poker players we've had
business people we've had athletes we've
had comedians but we've never had
somebody who is a sort of like a social
media Entertainer slash only fan star
and the hook I would say for people who
want to be interested in this episode is
uh I think you've made something like
is this do I have this number right 30
million dollars through like
only fans and like your other kind of
platforms where people subscribe to you
yeah that's just on L.A fans though but
yes
just on only fast what is the do you
have like a total number that's even
more impressive oh God I haven't really
looked in a while but maybe like 40
million or something something like that
um potentially well fine find out the
only fans is like way more lucrative
than every other platform because even
the only fans competitors are either
like two new or in patreon's case like
driving away the girls so and are you
the number one person on only fans
um I was for a while I'm not really sure
what it is right now I haven't looked
since I was I just put it and like oh
I'm gonna put that on my link tree that
I could just stop looking at it
um but maybe it's been growing a lot
lately
what's customer churn like will they
stay for do measure churn by years or
months
it's people's lives you know some people
get girlfriends some people will just
like not have a job anymore so it's hard
to do like a year because hardly anyone
stays on for a year a very small
percentage
and one of the things that's cool about
you is a you're open about uh the
business side of things which is cool
you don't have to be you chose to be so
I'm curious uh why do you why do you why
did you decide all right I'm going to be
able to I'm going to share this because
I think it brings a lot of attention
good and bad probably bring some haters
out there who are outraged that
somebody's making over a million dollars
a month on only fans uh why'd you decide
to go public with your your income and
your earnings
well it's gonna sound kind of weird I
guess to custom people because I didn't
do it for like Pride or anything like
that it's it's really because my
Instagram that had like five million
followers over that a little bit got
banned from Mass reports and I needed a
way for people to still write about me
because that was my biggest reach and so
everything else was not nearly as much
reach so I just started writing about
the business stuff knowing that people
would write about it if it comes from a
pretty girl talking about business
suddenly oh she's a genius but if it's a
guy saying the same thing no one would
care so
that's true okay I like that that's a uh
that's I think a fair call out so you
basically publish that and then other
people started like news outlets and
stuff started re-aggregating the story
and then that drove new subscribers
basically so it was like it was a growth
channel for you yeah it was like you
know a new form of earned media
wow uh okay that's great and so I have a
bunch of questions Sam I want you to
jump in before I just sort of uh you
know go down my my list of like things
I've probably wanted to ask you because
I've seen you I worked at twitch my
company got acquired by twitch I was at
twitch and I was like all right so who's
who's killing it who's doing great and
you were always at the top of the list
and nobody inside the company would
really like talk about it that much
whereas they could give like you know
they're really excited about certain
things because it's like really good
feel good stories or um you know it's a
game that they play that they're really
excited about and I was like well what
about her she's doing great like what is
this over here I'm doing great and
um how do you like to be dude your name
do you like being how do you pronounce
it I don't even know I read it I've
never heard you say it amaranth and
that's how you like in this setting
that's how you like to be addressed or
dressed as Kate okay much easier uh yeah
I didn't know what you preferred so uh
when you are going to these like
meetings because I imagine like a like
at you YouTube and twitch and all these
places I imagine they have an account
manager or something that like courts
you and says hey Kate you uh you know we
love what you're doing do you want to
come to the office if you happen to be
in town and we can like tell you some
best practices I mean that's what they
do for like a Casey neistat or whoever
uh on YouTube when they do things like
that for you or first of all do they
even do that but if they do and you go
to the office is that like a
are these like people these corporate
people like comfortable having
conversations about this type of [__] I
mean that's just like because it's just
like a it's such a unique
I don't know it's just like unique I
don't often talk to people who are
making a living this way oh man I don't
get any of that so nobody gonna wait to
the office no really how many you know
the owner of only fans is a big fan of
the podcast and so he's gonna listen to
this and so maybe maybe he can invite
you to the office and start giving you
the white glove treatment that like
probably a twitch or a YouTube or
whoever is maybe a little more hesitant
to do yeah maybe
um wait so how many followers do you
have on Twitch like 6 million
and they don't like reach out to you and
be like hey we just want to say thank
you for like being part of our platform
like here's a t-shirt or like like you
don't get anything like okay please make
this uh please make your skirt two
inches longer to comply with the latest
uh terms and conditions that would be
nice really they just ban people and
they don't tell you why
so you don't know what to change they'll
just suspend yes
Sam doesn't watch Twitch so let me just
describe this you're kind of like an
innovator on Twitch and I say that
laughingly because like it's twitch and
like let's not take it all too seriously
but like uh there's this trend where
um I think they call it hot tub
streaming basically where it's like yeah
I saw that it's like what's an excuse to
kind of like wear like a bikini and be
on stream which is like you know gonna
get you a bunch of viewers and like
subscriptions on Twitch but also in your
case like get you a bunch of people who
want to go you know down the funnel and
go to your maybe your only fans or
whatever and um I don't know if you were
the first were you like kind of the
first to start doing that or uh did you
just like make it more popular uh well
it's complicated because I started doing
pool streams outside you know like a
year or two before that and then um then
girls started doing hot to blow up like
inflatable hot tubs I think I was the
first one to bring it inside my room and
I've really popularized that one and
then there's like this like outrage and
people are like you gotta shut this down
and it's usually like people on the
platform who feel like oh it's taking
away views for me which I think is
kind of silly because it's like those
people weren't weren't going to watch
you uh you know like it's not like right
people come to get the type of
entertainment they want and they may not
want to watch you uh you know in your
basement playing like you know Dragon
Ball Z or whatever so it's like it's a
different it's a different thing but
there is this like uh outrage around it
what what do you uh I guess like do you
respond to that or how do you how do you
think about that
people being like jealous of others
having success and it's just placing
blame on them instead of looking in the
word and being like what could I improve
make my stream more appealing to people
and so they just want to point fingers
like you're why I'm not successful when
really we're if we're not taking away
views from Gamers certainly not if
anything we're taking away views from
PornHub but that's about it
how big of a game changer was only fans
for you so I'm looking at your only fans
I think you started I think you posted
you started April 2020 so only two years
ago and the first month you did 74 000
in on only fans then you did Thirty one
thousand sixteen thousand six thousand
something like that so you started off
with a big spike because you get a bunch
of people to come over and then you know
but you did really well right off the
bat a were you expecting that and B had
you like kind of already made it was
that like not that big of a deal
compared to what you were already doing
at twitch or was that a game changer
um I think it was probably somewhere in
the middle uh it was kind of what I
expected just because like that's you
know how platforms happen I already had
patreon before which was similar but
patreon was kind of pissing people off
and changing what they allowed on their
platform so only fans was like becoming
the patreon replacement for a lot of
people so I just kind of like
acquired that as well I didn't jump ship
because I still have my patreon so I
said both now and I even have a fancy
um but it wasn't really like that
shocking I guess at first because I was
already seeing those kinds of numbers on
patreon and a pretty decent amount on
Twitch at that time
what were uh how big's your team or is
it just you I mean no how do you I have
uh an entire staff of my sort of like
personal assistants video editors
photographers Etc
um so right now in the office I have
like five main people and then I also
have my extended staff that I kind of
bounce back and forth between here in
the office because they work also with
me on real work my Agency for like of
creators and family Etc like different
girls and and guys or some guys on there
too
um so yeah I have like I have extended
staff and I have like my immediate at my
house is usually four to five people
always
do you consider yourself like the CEO of
the business or do you have like a
straight person like a like a by the
book person who's like making sure
everything's running on time or are you
that person
um I guess I'm I could technically be
called the CEO but I don't manage it as
much day to day as like my uh my head
staff that I have my managing directors
for it
and we uh so we got to know Mr Beast
recently we went to we like had an event
and uh like a kind of like a Basketball
Camp or whatever he came and and we had
we had him on the Pod and he's a
obviously super impressive guy he gets
this like kind of amazing coverage in
the news everything is like Mr Beast
he's a good dude but like the coverage
is like pretty much exclusively good
obviously there's some haters you know
always but like people think he's
amazing business people really respect
him for his like business Acumen and
he's you know seen as one of the biggest
content creators
but um I would say you're like your
franchise is right up there with him if
you just took if you just took the the
sort of like the face off the business
if I just showed you the p l of both
businesses
I think you would be like well I want
her p l right because you're making
almost as much money with way less
expenses with way less staff and
overhead probably with more valuable
customers more loyal customers and um
and then on top of that you're like the
moves you're making off your streams or
off your off your platforms where you've
got the agency
um and then you've got the you know all
your Investments and stuff like that
it's just like what he's doing with his
agency and his Investments and all that
but I feel like you don't get that same
coverage or if you do it's like could
you believe this uh you know she's doing
she's doing like you know real business
things like how does that I guess like
do you agree with my assessment there
and how do you feel about that
um yeah I guess the main difference is
the platform that I'm doing it on
because uh you know of is already gonna
have like a bias behind it people don't
want to admit that they pay attention to
it even if they do and then twitch also
is a smaller much smaller platform than
YouTube so it just doesn't have the same
amount of reach even if it's like the
same model in the same like type of
stuff it just doesn't reach nearly as
many people as like his YouTube channel
would how big do you think this this
gets so like I don't know what you're
doing annually now but maybe it's like
15 million or something like that uh how
big do you think that this this can get
and how big do you want it to get well I
don't know because it
typically grow real work really
girls accounts it can potentially grow
like a huge Network and that's kind of
like in my extended Empire but um Me by
myself I don't know I never even thought
I'd get you this far so it kind of just
happens really quickly especially once
pandemic start and everyone was just
online all the time
well when you're when you're laying in
bed at night and you're like I mean when
I go to bed at night I'm like man like
that was like I had a good day whatever
it's really inspiring I I dream of I
think I I think I could do this I think
I could like do this one thing that's
like crazy and and I just think like
well in 10 years maybe this little thing
could be this this and this what do you
what do you imagine like what's your
dream even if it's outlandish to say
sometimes or maybe it's not I don't know
but like what's your dream on where you
want to take your your career well
hopefully
like year to three years and just kind
of stream part time like a few days a
week maybe and then just have my Empire
for a real work have grown so much maybe
we have like 50 to 100 of creators that
we just kind of provide virtual
assistance for and then I my legacy kind
of lives on through that and then I
don't feel like I have to grind every
day and can just work with animals on
stream a few days a week it's really fun
and explain what real work is so this is
like an agency started it's not from
what I understand it's not a talent
agency it's like a uh we can like the
system you built with your back office
with your assistants and those people
you offer that as a service basically to
others who don't have that back office
but like I guess describe it in your
words yeah I guess it would be like
virtual assistants like like a team put
together that other creators can have
access to where they'll help like edit
your content post your content Market it
like write up descriptions and push
sales on your platforms and stuff and
then occasionally like I do events where
I have girls from an agency come over
and we stream together we collab Etc so
it's kind of like helping others grow
and then managing that growth to provide
like more efficient sales across their
platforms let's say that like I couldn't
afford to hire your uh team and I just
said but is there like just like a
handful of bullet points that you could
tell me on how to have a successful uh
page like you do like what are the what
are the like 1 5 10 bullet points that
you would say well do this do this do
this do this do this well I think if you
want to grow you really do need help
whether that's just like your friends
maybe if you have like a really cool
sibling family someone close enough to
you or they can physically come over and
help you with shoots help you get your
content out there like edited posted Etc
because if you want to grow you also
have to be putting out
um like content on public non-shadow
band platforms like Twitter Youtube Tick
Tock is huge right now Tech talk is
really easy to grow on compared to the
other ones right now twitch actually
isn't that great for growth unless you
have other platforms already I would
save twitch for last if you're even
contemplating it because it has no
Discovery system that makes any sense
it's all just recommended and what gets
recommended people who already have
viewers how do you get viewers you have
to have an audience from somewhere
so switch is actually like the the least
I would say lucrative for new people
um time will be better spent on like
YouTube shorts Instagram reels tick
tocks and you kind of just share that
content with all three of them and make
it very efficient but just kind of grow
your audience from there
if that makes sense what do you um for
the agency uh what do you charge how do
you how do you charge money for it and
uh like how many clients do you have
right now oh we take a percentage
um of the girls earnings yeah we start
with like a like a three-month trial
period and if they don't like it they
don't like we're providing value beyond
what they were already doing then then
we just we won't continue on it like we
don't lock them in for like a year or
two that's like really scummy to me
what's the Benchmark but what's the
Benchmark of what you think they should
earn should they be earning 100 Grand a
month a million I mean what what do you
it really just depends
um we don't really have a benchmark
right now we kind of just look at their
socials look at like how much reach they
have relative to how many people have
already converted to their platforms to
see if like okay well we can work with
that there's some potential here
um if it's a really bad conversion maybe
maybe not you know but if it's like it's
relative to how big they are already
here's a dangerous question but I am
curious what works for conversion like
we talk in the startup World about
growth hacks all the time it's like oh
did you know that when Airbnb started
they didn't have any listings so they
scraped Craigslist local house listings
they made them all on Airbnb and they
messaged people on on Craigslist saying
hey I saw your listing on Airbnb uh can
I book through there and it was just a
robot sending it and then that caught
people to to put their listing up so
startups have these like classic growth
hacks things that unlocked new sales or
tactics that unlock new sales
um on your road to making millions and
millions dollars on only fans what are
the growth hacks what are the things
that work best for for growth for you
and for for the girls that you manage
gosh that's so tough because things have
worked before and then algorithms change
and they don't so it's been like an
evolution of what's worked like I don't
actually like I'm not gonna do it so you
don't actually actually give me the
original things that work what are the
stories that are like oh that's funny
that that worked or that's cool that
that worked uh I want the more
entertaining stories not the boring
stuff that actually you know works over
time
yeah well what used to work um really
well before Instagram really cracked
down was
um you could have long descriptions of
being like um
spam spam like uh a word if you saw my
latest juicy content people would be
like spamming a word that was like it's
like moist or something in it
what did I miss now we go back to the
caption and they'd still be confused and
they would click on the profile and they
would see the link in the bio stuff like
that that's hilarious yeah
I'm like the kind of like provocative
words like letter by letter so people
would be like what is happening and
other games right they have to like it's
not what they're used to seeing so then
they had to go investigate to find out
yeah yeah or other things I would do
would be like um
tell me when you see her I would play
like I spy in in the pictures and then
would be like a swipe image on each
different image there would be like a
like check the link in the bio for
really good content like just like words
like on a shirt so the algorithm
couldn't detect it like like curved with
the with the shape of the shirt and
stuff like you'd have to like zoom in
and stuff and then the comments would be
like right shoulder right shoulder right
shoulder so people would like Zoom it
and it would be great I really missed
that that's that's that's that's a
really good one too why do you miss that
you can't do that anymore I mean my my
main Instagram got banned so now I'm
just now I just play things super safe
yeah yeah and you um you're wearing this
like uh only fans like tube top or
whatever right now do they give those to
you to like is that their company swag
to like promote help promote their site
or you make it yeah I think I actually
bought it from the website but I
probably could have asked I just it was
cheaper just to buy it or faster because
time is money so I'm just like
and what were you doing before this
because you're clearly like smart and a
hustler and like whatever were you like
did you have a good job at like you know
Blockbuster back in the day like what
what was the career before you became
this person who you became I had a
really weird one because most people
they do like work retail or like uh
waitressing or something I actually
Blockbuster shot Blockbuster I'm doing
her thing where I throw in a random word
that's why these YouTube comments are
gonna be like Blockbuster Blockbuster
it's gonna help I'm learning from it
wait but hold on how old are you 28.
so no way is she gonna be working on a
blockbuster
I used to get games when I was a kid but
once once I was 16 there was not really
a blockbuster anymore
wait what was the weird job yeah I
actually it's really wholesome I did
character parties for kids birthdays and
hospital visits and like festivals
around town Make-A-Wish Foundation stuff
I was like princesses and superheroes so
that was my company so you would dress
up in Cosplay and basically like I'd go
to a kids party or a hospital basically
yeah basically
yeah and that was my my little startup
Entertainment Company what an amazing
pivot that's the best pivot I've ever
heard uh like you know Instagram used to
be this like location app that just
happened to have photos and then they
were like let's just go all in on the
photos and you basically were like
I'm gonna go all in on the costume thing
but like instead of little kids who do
like big kids
I still feel like I'm babysitting on
Twitch too so yeah exactly
that's amazing and you pay like uh you
know I have this researcher who helps me
with the Pod and um I was like hey she's
coming on um and I like to not know
everything because if you know
everything you come in and you just ask
questions you already know the answers
to it's kind of boring
um and so but he did surface one
interesting thing in his uh research
which was he's like yeah there's like
you know leaked stuff on online where
you don't have to pay for the only fans
you can just like find something
remove it but but he was like he's like
I think she has like a like an on like
retainer like you know Bloodhound agency
or or a lawyer or something that's
trying to like just shut all these down
how what is there like a cat and mouse
game if you're trying to like keep your
content behind the paywall and do you
like pay how much do you pay per month
to like prevent protect yourself
yeah we have um a whole like little dmca
staff here
um
it's a it's a combined effort like I I
do have uh lawyers yeah why but why are
you paying for that only fans doesn't
offer that no
what yeah
I have a I have my own little like um
that's a startup opportunity Create A
Little Agency that's gonna do that for
all only fans creators
Insurance yeah
um but it's it's funny though because I
streamed so much that like I have a very
close relationship I guess with like the
moderators of my chat on my Discord they
will actually actively like find leaks
because people do something stupid which
is on my twitch Channel they'll try to
uh viewers will will start mass dming at
people like leaks here leaks here leaks
here then my mods are just like boops
into my do you see anything then we're
gonna delete it so they're just like
self-reporting I don't have to go
looking for them they ended up just
exposing all the leaks to me already
and so Mr Beast when when we were
hanging out with the Mr Beast so we he
we did a power with him and Sean and I
flew down and got to talk to him and uh
the maybe the most there was a bunch of
fascinating things about him but one of
the more fascinating things that a lot
of people don't know is so he's like
this big shot in America and uh has all
these followers but YouTube's Global and
so he decided to hire a team to start
um translating his stuff meeting like
they would they would dub his content
with voice actors and what he did was
really interesting is he would actually
over you know a lot of people would be
like oh let's just get the cheapest
person who kind of sounds interesting
and I believe he would overpay where he
would get like the guy who voiced a
famous character in Brazil would also
voice Mr Beast and everyone thought that
was pretty cool and it sounds neat and
so all creators were like hey do that
for us and he goes yeah sure I'll do it
for you and I I forget how it works but
I believe he takes a percentage of those
I'll spin up your you know Portuguese
Channel and we'll manage it we'll have a
we have a person who speaks Portuguese
they'll write the descriptions we'll
have the voice actors we'll do all that
stuff and we take like I don't know 30
of the revenue of that YouTube channel
for them to do that for me in Turkish
because I have a huge Turkish audience
because porn and ban
exactly those repressed Turkish people
they they need it so they need my
tryouts in Turkish but they they like do
you talk much
anyways universal language
but what's yeah that's a good point but
what's interesting is you I don't know
if you're doing this because you're
trying to be humble but you're kind of
downplaying I think like the the [__]
that you're doing you're like oh I just
have these like personal assistants and
you know we just yeah it could be you're
just being humble but have you thought
about like
kind of like scaling this like crazy
Beast or Jimmy just raised some like 200
million dollars at like a 1.5 million
billion dollar valuation have you
thought about being like well no that's
like we're not just gonna call it
personal assistance we're going hard at
this and we're gonna completely
operationalize and help this niche of
content creators have you ever thought
about like
kind of from that angle up as opposed to
like I don't know maybe you're just
being nice but it kind of sounds like
you're downplayed I think that's what
we're trying to do with real work we
just started at the like a few months
ago so it was my personal assistance
that we're kind of turning into an
actual organization you um you're very
like uh nonchalant uh about that's what
I mean about your I'm trying to figure
out where what gets you basically
excited about what you've done because I
think you're basically like it's it's
not new to you right when you tell it
when we hear what you're doing it's kind
of mind-blowing what do you hear what
you're doing you're like yeah I know
that's what I do every day right it's
not gonna like it's not gonna be
mind-blowing to you but there's got to
be some part of you that's like
holy [__] I can't believe this is what's
happening and like oh my God like this
could be blah blah blah and there's got
to be some part of you that still has
that I don't know
less laid back and more excited part of
you that's like yeah I really want this
and I know that's gonna be crazy but
like I think I could do it uh is there
some part of this that's like really
mind-blowing to you or like really
exciting for you going forward
it's pretty mind-blowing
day like this is how it is and then
doing more and more over time you kind
of just get desensitized because it's
such like a slow process over the past
six years I feel slow to me anyways I do
it so much
um
but yeah I mean I really want to do
animal content on my twitch stream and
you know I'm hoping to move towards that
soon kind of away from like so much of
the e-girl
like side like I'm still gonna be an
eagle I guess to people who want to
Brand it as that but like I feel like
content can be so much more than sitting
in a hot tub you know when you're saying
when you're saying animal content I'm
not a twitch person when you're saying
animal content is that a phrase for
something else or is that literally no
no like I have horses and dogs that I
want to do like twitch stream teams with
and training and trail riding and taking
care of them and having a stable in a
ranch in the near future hopefully
can find this client info have you heard
of HubSpot
ERM platform so it shares its data
across every application every team can
stay aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
or dueling databases HubSpot grow better
do you have like
um
like a therapist or anybody because like
I've seen what like how twitch streamers
like what they have to put up with and
like there's this crazy like love hate
weirdo stalker thing that happens then
you get famous on Twitch and like you
get a lot of like you know you know you
you see comments that are super negative
you see comments that are super like
like super positive it's just like a lot
to take in while you're just sitting at
home in your room streaming for like
eight hours which is kind of an
unnatural thing without saying the light
of day during that time right like do
you do like mental health do you do
anything proactively for mental health
so that you're not like going nuts while
you do this uh well I do have a
therapist now for some other reasons but
I probably should have had one this
whole time for streaming as well but my
kind of mental health I guess outside of
therapy would just be horse riding it's
kind of like my meditation replacement
is that stuff at does that stuff
actually get to you like uh I do a
decent job of you know it's actually
funny I do a decent job of like ignoring
haters we're not nearly as big as you
but we still get like you know hundreds
of comments a a day of like hate or good
and bad and uh like I recently got fit
and I remember people commenting of like
oh you look less fat or um they'll say
like um oh you know today you're looking
a little chubby and I was like damn
these people are mean you must get like
thousands I mean you do thousands of
people a day commenting on your looks
does that actually get to you are you
are you pretty good of uh of kind of
I don't know ignoring it uh I'd say it
used to get to me more but at this point
I just kind of immune to it I think
um yeah it's not so much comments they
get to me what gets to me is comparison
to myself because I'll I'll on a photo
shoot day say I'm feeling bloated or I'm
breaking out or whatever and I'll be
referencing like pictures that did well
on my social media before just so we
know like what to recreate that we have
done in a while and it's like man it
looks so good there I was like [__]
today like things like that because like
at the time you know it's like the
perfect lighting the perfect angle or
whatever and it just doesn't look that
way in the mirror you know but then
usually it did done with the shoot and
you're like oh these are fine like
because it looks different on camera so
the reality is what [__] me up not
really people's comments or maybe it's
like a child actor thing and like in 15
years all the like famous twitch
streamers are going to be like you know
I'll screwed up it's like they were fine
at the time but it was all good it's
like later when things get weird
um you know you you ha you also tweet
about like what you do with your money
which I think is kind of interesting
um we'll talk about the gas station
thing in a second but like we always ask
you know the guests who come on we say
all right cool like money's this weird
thing where it's kind of Taboo it's like
in entrepreneurship you're supposed to
say that's not about the money for me
but like they fight like hell to like
every point of equity and every dollar
earned it's like clearly money does
matter to people and they also don't
really say what they do with their money
and therefore there's a bunch of people
who are listening to podcasts like this
that don't know
like there's like an information wall
it's like um you don't get to know what
happens on the side it's like only
through many years in hard lessons you
get to figure it out and we think that's
kind of silly we try to like break down
that wall a little bit
um so if I was going to describe to you
like a pie chart like okay here's all
your money
um where do you what do you do with it
uh do you just leave it in a checking
account are you putting in the stock
market are you buying crypto like can
you roughly draw us like a pie chart of
like you know how you manage your own
money
um
it's kind of complicated I I didn't
really get to manage it as much until
recently but um the gas stations yeah
those are those are a fun investment
though uh my accountant actually brought
me to that one and um they help save me
on taxes because I can I got to expense
the entire cost of the building up front
so that reduced my my my yearly income
on paper and then I had like a lower tax
rate depreciate accelerated depreciation
yeah exactly
um so that was that kind of thing you
have to be like a real estate
professional technically right so you're
doing like the 500 hour test basically
uh no you actually don't don't have to
be with this
explain that to me I want to do that do
you know I thought it's basically if
you're passive then it could only offset
passive income but your other stuff is
active income right so do I have a
misunderstanding or does it work
differently uh I just don't want my
account my accountant team brushed me
they said there was this opportunity and
they explained to me like okay so I'm
just putting money into that and then uh
yeah they kind of have all the rest of
the details I just throw the money at it
is most of your uh is most of your is
most of your portfolio just in boring
index funds
[Music]
she bought like a million dollars of
Visa stock the other day yeah I mean
that's like a really that's a reliable
thing it's not going anywhere especially
since pandemic is kind of at least the
fear of it is dying down people are out
there traveling more getting out more
it's just only gonna get better it's
also like a cash back program for you
you've probably paid like nearly a
million dollars in credit card shoes uh
two visa and now yeah it's a way to sort
of what else did you buy I mean I asked
some Google I have some Shopify
um at Amazon uh yeah I have some crypto
but I don't I don't know how I feel
about crypto yet
why not because I just it's it's so up
and down all the time that it's just I I
can't tell what it's really gonna do so
yeah I have some Bitcoin where do you
when you're when you're researching
which what do you want to buy where uh
where do you learn like what resources
do you turn to well I have
I have an accounting team and I also
have you know YouTube and Google like
everyone else
yeah on Google and YouTube what do you
who do you listen to
I don't really have like a certain
person I guess it's just kind of like I
get linked various things that people
send me
yeah I used to actually talk to a lot of
streamers about it in my DMs
um you know I don't know if you guys
knew who reckful was maybe you actually
worked at twitch um we used to talk
about stocks in our DMS so that's kind
of where I got started with it and then
I was just sent stuff and kind of
explored it and then I got like an
accountant and it all just kind of
compiles from everywhere do you do any
other type of investing that's
interesting so you you is it one gas
station or multiple and then you have
stocks is there anything else
well I have some businesses I've bought
and some private Equity too
tell me more tell us something I can't
really talk about the private Equity
because it's private I legally I can't
say anything about much about it but
basically they just acquire small
businesses throughout the year and um I
send them money as needed up to like 5
million or so is what the total will be
but on a deal by deal basis basically
yeah yeah whatever they need it they
call for it there's not like a scheduled
payment system with it gotcha and then
what about uh businesses you bought what
do you what are the what are you buying
and who's running these things well
usually I buy businesses that can just
run themselves like um I guess the the
if you guys heard about like the ball
pit company or like the ball the plastic
ball company I used for my ball pit no
no what is that
it's just it's it's like a I probably
manufacturer they're based in China
though they make like playground balls
like uh you know like ball pit type yeah
it was just like really yeah see it was
just really
um
Chinese manufacturer
well the like that they share the
facility with other people but um yeah
they manufacture balls and I bought that
company
it was really it's actually a really
good profit margins like how did this
even come across your desk accountant
accountant they just sent me stuff
they're like they're saying and I like
the gravity towards the ones that I can
also use for publicity stunts and uh on
Twitch so like I turned my entire room
into a ball pit
your accountant is like the LeBron James
of accountants or the Bernie Madoff of
accounts I haven't decided which one yet
but he's doing way more than the Call of
Duty as an accountant yeah I'm like a
team it's it's hard to explain it all I
I normally I just throw them the money
I'm like yes make it work are you afraid
of like being one of those like athletes
that goes broke on like you know my my
manager my accountant talked me into
buying these like this chain of you know
Wendy's that was like non-existent and
ran away with my money because it sounds
like uh yeah you're throwing money into
crazy places right now is that a fear
for you uh no oh no not really
um if you're not afraid I'm not afraid
yeah I had bigger fears than that
it it uh it almost like we were asking
you some of these like super specific
money questions and it people are
listening now but uh you know you're the
look in your face was like why the [__]
are these guys asking me all these
questions about this money [__] like
this makes me uncomfortable isn't that
hilarious I only recently got back in
control of my finances I don't know if
y'all saw that drama but uh what
happened I can't say too much about it
but um I got out of kind of a uh
controlling relationship a bit so
yeah yeah yeah we keep the dark stuff
over there we just do the money stuff
here we we don't we don't worry we we
try not to get into the heavy topics
what I was saying was you do things that
99.9 of people would find to be
incredibly embarrassing for to do like
they would be they would be too nervous
to do that you know it's too taboo I'm
uncomfortable doing that and I think
that it's
it's wild that we think that all right
we're okay with that and but we're also
nervous about talking about the money
thing and like that's just like an
interesting insight and we've talked to
so many people and it's very rare that
someone's comfortable talking about
money it still makes me really
uncomfortable but it's just like an
interesting thing it's like Oh I thought
this woman wasn't afraid of anything but
when we talk about money like you know
it's it can be a weird topic yeah no I'm
pretty comfortable talking about the
money so much like some of the more like
investment business sites it's not just
me so I was like I can feel like I can't
talk too much about it because I'm not
like the only person driving those types
of things so when we were talking to Mr
Beast he's been going into like you know
uh feastables like his chocolate bar and
then he created like a pop-up uh like
Cloud Kitchen restaurant thing called
Beast burger and he's like talking about
different like businesses where he can
go into and say okay I could use my fame
and my distribution to like give these
businesses an unfair advantage
um are you doing it sounds like the ball
pit is sort of like that where you're
like okay if I buy this company and I I
make it part of my content then like you
know sales could go up but like I can
imagine like any of the taboo sort of
like or like you know whatever sex
related type of products whether it's
like you know it could be swimwear it
could be lingerie it could be sex toys
it could be like who knows I don't know
I don't know what else it could be like
are you going down that pathway like we
should actually like either buy or
create a business like in that in those
categories and use me and maybe the the
other my other you know other girls I
know that will be a part of promoting
this and like we can blow this company
up into a pretty big company are you
thinking along those lines
yeah I am uh definitely for the future
as I'm I'm trying to move towards you
know more uh collaborative efforts with
other girls with the real work so I I
really want to do like lingerie
um I think makeup is a good way to go to
um beauty industry is huge but uh yeah
definitely like those are on my mind
right now do you have to do products
that guys want or is it products like
like how many of your fans are women
versus men
it's going to be a mixture it's looking
like since um I'm blowing up more now
where it's like I do have more of a
female audience especially like since a
lot of the girls kind of look to me as a
person to follow as far as like the of
side goes e-girl side whatever you want
to call it
um so it's getting more balanced but
yeah I also still have a a project that
I've been working on with Ludwig this
past year we're making an amaranth
Fleshlight so yeah that's kind of what I
was thinking about
we're doing that too that was the idea
that I was thinking about it yeah
dude have you uh have you guys ever
heard of kink.com have you heard of
kink.com
all right so kink.com was like I I think
that they were a website but also the
parent company and they owned all these
like fetish websites so you know Kinks
and uh I don't know what they all were
but like one of them or one of them that
was pretty funny was like these people
who would like wrestle and then have sex
and this guy started it wrestling
yeah well they like no but they were
like Olympic wrestling like they were
wearing like unitards and then like they
it warps into sex and whatever and they
uh the guy who started it it was just a
guy and he started it in the late 90s
doing the.com boom so he was an early
mover and he built it into a huge
business and eventually he bought this
old Armory which is basically a huge
building in the center of the Mission
District in San Francisco which is
considered some of the most expensive
real estate in the city because it's
like a desirable hipster neighborhood
and he built this huge thing and it was
basically like a palace it was like an
airplane imagine an airplane hangar but
like in the one of the more desirable
neighborhoods of San Francisco and he
owned it and they eventually would film
all their [__] there so like they had
like a wrestling area and then they had
like a bar where they would do like
people who like to have sex in public
they like mimicked a bar and people
would have sex in it and film it and
they would charge subscribers money
whatever and when I first moved to San
Francisco I took a Groupon tour of it
like you could like you could because
it's just like an interesting building
that's an old Armory where they like
it's like an old historical building and
it's also a porn studio and I was
hanging out with this girl and she was
like hey do you want to go like see this
thing it's on Groupon it's a it's a porn
Studio we could just go take a tour of a
historical building and I was like yeah
s and that's how I learned with kink.com
was I went and like oh you see the stuff
and I'm like this is crazy and then I
started thinking about like
all these media companies like uh Jimmy
and I used to do it too would be like oh
we want to become like the Disney of
blank and I'm like oh this guy at Kink
that's his Disney's Disneyland like he
like he had all these people taking
tours to come I think we spent 50 bucks
and we got a tour where they're like
here's where like the Army used to
prepare now we use it as a dungeon for
sex tapes because like there's a hose
here so we could spray people with water
like it was all Kink stuff and it was
pretty wild that this was like part of
their business model and like the people
on that tour like I'm a pretty straight
laced guy it was like straight laced
people who had no idea what this website
was and then there was other people that
were like totally into it and they're
like oh I'm seeing where this I'm seeing
the studio where my favorite stuff is
filmed it was incredibly fascinating
Sean I've never abstract you haven't
heard of that it was like right in the
middle I remember the building yeah I
didn't know the website part but yeah
that building is kind of famous it's a
beautiful building from the outside and
uh when you go by somebody will always
tell you you know hey this is what that
is
but if you look up like kink.com
Building San Francisco or something
there'll be a Wikipedia page and this
building it might be worth
north of 100 million dollars at this
point maybe more and it uh it's like a
huge building in a very desirable
neighborhood and it was just like super
fascinating this guy did this and so
maybe in the future what we're going to
see you have is we're gonna see you like
be like oh hey creators who work with me
do you want to like a come you want a
place to come and stay like uh you know
I can you could you could host your
office in my studio and then eventually
it's like hey uh fans of us whoever
wants to spend a hundred bucks you can
come get like a walking guided tour and
then eventually you're just gonna own
like all this amazing yeah red light
district style you're gonna own all this
real estate anyway it was a really
interesting play that these folks did
and it I think it I think the uh
building became worth more than their
the porn brand wow I I read something he
said that I thought was pretty
interesting you go I think you said this
it was uh
you go there's like the but Warren
Buffett has this phrase like you only
have to get rich once and you were
saying like for social media it's the
same thing you got to just build an
audience once yeah you only got to get
famous once and so what how did you
actually get famous what was the what
was the were there any big inflection
points where it like it went from like
you know not that many people watching
me or following me to like way more or
was it just very steady or were there
were there any like big moments
um I see the hearts of meta was probably
huge that was probably doubled my growth
at least
um but before that it was kind of just I
guess I entered the social media space
at a time when it wasn't over saturated
like 2016. it wasn't as crazy it is now
or everyone wants to be an influencer so
I think I got really lucky with the
timing and then I just was growing on
Twitch and twitch wasn't oversaturated
either at that time and I just kind of
grew with the platform because I
streamed so much you know and what
separated me from others was I was also
making content on pretty much every
other platform at the same time like I
had Facebook page I had Instagram I had
Twitter I had YouTube and I was just
kind of growing it plus patreon also
kind of boosted my ability to just make
that my full-time thing because I wasn't
relying just on Twitch I didn't have to
keep like a day job or whatever describe
how intense the content like work is
because I think some people would say oh
man you just post a picture on only fans
that's why like you make 100 Grand a
month you know you make a million
dollars a month uh and all you got to do
is like post a pic like you know once a
day or whatever like that's it what is
the what's the reality like
uh right now my content schedule is a
little crazy but pretty much every week
I'll have like a day or two where I just
dedicate to only fans and fansy and
patreon like all my uh NSFW platforms
and then I also like the next day I'll
do all my YouTube Twitter Instagram
content as well so pretty much two days
out of the week are like 12 hour photo
shoot days across all my different types
of content and then the rest of the time
I'll just stream on Twitch because
that's kind of my my billboard that pays
me
[Laughter]
there's no reason it's completely
illogical why I feel this way but it is
just funny to like hear like you know
Sean and I talk about the exact same
[__] it's just like in such a
uh just with different types of content
and it's so funny that it's like it it
just not a normal conversation that we
typically have where it's with uh not
safe for work content and I think that's
so cool
yeah it's very different for sure
but it's all the same mechanics and it's
just like what and in my head I'm like
why do I think what like she's just
doing the exact same [__] we do it's
just a different Niche and frankly a
significantly bigger significantly more
profitable and significantly uh like you
just use you just like we're happy with
like a million dollar a year maybe if
like in the tech World on the Twitter
world and it's just like oh yeah that's
cool I'm I'm I'm decently happy with a
million dollar a month too yeah it's
kind of crazy so I'm just trying to get
it while you know the getting is good
because I feel like it's such a rare
opportunity to have I don't waste it do
you
um like okay so you're like you know
doing really well with this stuff now uh
do you what's the is there like an end
of the road where you're like okay I'm
just gonna like I have to retire at
certain point and like you know
do you sort of see like I have a very
small window here for this or do you
think it's going to be much longer than
that
um I do feel like I have a small window
compared to
honestly based off my appearance and
there's always younger people coming
into this space
um but yeah I don't know how much longer
I don't have like a cut off period I
would think I would like to be done with
the grind within the next year
maybe three max
um if somebody's confused by the way
because like when I first heard about
only fans I was like why would I pay
like orange free what do you mean uh why
would I pay five dollars a month for
this uh is there like some psycho
psychological benefit that people get
out of it like you know what drives
somebody to actually pay for something
when there's so much of a free
alternative available to them
um out there on the internet
I think part of it is the parasocial
aspect where it's like they feel like
they kind of like know this person
because they'd see them on either
YouTube or twitch or whatever it is
um
some people go overboard with it like
they treat it like it's just my
girlfriend which is definitely not not
your girlfriend bro
um but yeah I feel like part of it's
just like they they like a certain
person's kind of look like they're
really into whatever characteristics
make of that Creator and they want to
see more from that specific look that
they've become like attracted to I guess
or have some form of attachment just
from seeing their face so much Sam have
you ever heard this word parasocial
you've used that word and then the word
about when you were talking about
spamming the comments I've never like
heard someone call it that was that was
an interesting one too
um parasocial is basically like a
one-sided well air quotes relationship
that the viewer has with the content
creator like some people get way too
invested in a uh Creator's personal life
like they want to know who they're
dating what they did today where they've
been why aren't they online right now
that's I would say that's a very
parasocial thing it's like they feel
like more entitled to a relationship
when they don't actually know the person
but it's a I mean but that that's good
for you no
um and some until it gets to like a
stalker threatening level
the Creator
but how many times do you think it
crosses the line like how often would
that happen to you where it actually is
an issue
[Music]
per day in messages I'm sure there's
even more that I don't read but as far
as in-person altercations
um typically if a few a year will try to
physically show up at your house but
then you get a horde of people also just
trying to swat you and docs you in
general who are mad that either you're
not dating them or you didn't respond or
whatever
so it's complicated crazy yeah people
are insane
we I'm glad we're not famous well we
Sean and I get like one percent of that
because sometimes people will hear Sean
talk and they're like oh you're really
good at talking about money and like
you're pretty successful therefore like
show me the way uh what the hell you
didn't reply to me like after all I do
for you yeah and like that's like one
percent I'm sure of what you get because
it's when love and all that shit's
involved it's just like way more intense
yeah and way more dangerous I think
um it's like what would someone do like
they just they just think that hey what
the hell man I I messaged you and like
we were talking and I thought we were
together now you're still doing this
stuff
yeah some people get catfished too but I
like people just pretending to be me and
so they'll be like okay all this money
and you didn't show up and I'm like oh
no oh no
um but yeah typically it's just crazy
people who are just basically talking to
themselves a one-sided conversation in
the DM's never getting a response and
they just keep going they just keep
going I feel like uh I feel like I could
create an AI only fans Creator and
um probably like just crush it because
she could do anything and she would talk
to anyone any time of day and she would
you know be you know the girlfriend you
always wanted and so if anyone out there
is a uh an engineer who wants to help me
with this let's for a stunt let's try to
create an AI only fans a girl who's
gonna make a million dollars in a month
that's the mission and we'll publish how
we're doing along the way and we're
gonna learn all the growth hacks and
we're gonna put it all out there and
they can't doctor or sweater because she
doesn't exist she doesn't live anywhere
and so uh I think it is the uh maybe the
future there so so that's mine so listen
to that action anybody who wants to help
me with that project get in my DMs on
Twitter Sean VP
have you guys seen uh Avid is it called
Avatar dot me yeah have you guys seen it
all right so check this out so there's
like all this like AI [__] where you
it's like all built on the back of one
thing and then all these people are
creating plugins and layers on tops of
top of it and so there's this new thing
where you can upload 20 pictures of
yourself and it will give you avatars
created uh with you in mind and okay I
did go to avatarai dot me that's the
that's not it's [__] amazing so check
this out so I just uploaded a bunch of
pictures of my face and there were a few
pictures that I posted of my body
because I was doing like before and
after of like Fitness [__] but it sent
me photos back of me looking like a
dominatrix
but then it gave me this other picture
that I have no idea what this is it gave
me this other picture where it's
supposed to be like I only post gave it
pictures of me with like my stomach up
and it and it like gave it made me it
like made a fake picture of my ass and
it was just like a picture of my butt
and uh it's [__] disgusting and weird
but like but I was looking at this and
I'm like oh there definitely should be
there's definitely gonna be this type of
thing because have you guys seen uh
I think it's called replica.ai it's
basically a service where you can like
you can just spend money and you get
like a friend that learns how to
interact with you and you also can get
like an online girlfriend who just is
like it's a text-based conversation that
you're having with this fake woman and
she gets to know you and figures out
your taste and likes it's all built on
AI now we just got to add it with some
of this um with some of these uh
pictures and then eventually deep fake
videos and like
your job ultimately is going to be
completely like you know unnecessary
like the use of the world are going to
be it's like hey wait you're real why
would you do why are you wasting that
time being real uh you know uh or like
maybe there should be like bots of you
that understand your personality and
actually do talk to these men and you
can like license out your your face to
replica.ai there's gonna be a lot of
interesting things like that I think in
the near in like the next two years
probably
yeah for sure it's getting kind of crazy
the technology
uh right on all right well listen this
is great I'm glad you came on uh thanks
for doing this and uh where should
people uh where should we find you if
they want to uh you know see more learn
more
get to know you a little bit better uh
you're just for perfect with my link
directory and the URL is easy to
remember it's downbed.com
whatdownbad.com yes downbad.com okay
sounds easy uh okay it has all my
platforms listed there because sometimes
you know stuff gets banned and the link
will change so it's always there that's
cool all right thanks Kate appreciate it
yeah thanks appreciate you
[Music]
foreign